hello and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept in
biology in less than five minutes if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel so
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to leave your comments below
because that gives me the motivation to
make more videos in today's installment
we'll be talking about beer Lambert's
law simply beer-lambert law relates
absorbance of a sample to the
concentration so if you have a light
absorbing sample like this and depending
upon how much light it absorbs you can
have an estimation on the concentration
of the molecules that is present in the
solution so it's a pretty useful method
in spectroscopy in in whole biology so
before looking into the detailed
mechanism and deriving the formula and
knowing about the usage of this law let
us try to understand the workflow so
first we need to have our sample to be
loaded in a cuvette let's say our sample
is a light absorbing sample for now and
we put the sample in a spectrophotometer
and let's see what happens inside the
spectrophotometer the detection part
what happens inside that so there are
light sources inside the
spectrophotometer definitely there are
filter wheels which allow specific
wavelength of the light to be to be
falling on the specimen and ultimately
the light which passes through the
specimen hit the detector so here is the
arrangement inside the spectrophotometer
now according to beer Lambert's law the
absorbance is kind of proportional to
the concentration of the solution and
the light path of the qubit the path of
the light that the light travels inside
the sample now let's say the intensity
of the light which is falling on the
sample is i0
and after passing through the sample its
intensity is IT or let's say only I so
if the sample is absorbing some amount
of light then you can clearly imagine
the value of I T is the transmitted
light intensity is lower than the
incident light intensity and a ratio a
log ratio of these two intensities are
actually termed as absorbance which they
related to the concentration and the
path length and this is basically the
beer-lambert law now clearly you can
understand from this law it tells us
that absorbance is a function of
concentration and the path length now
there are two assumptions first
assumption tells us that absorbance is
can propulsion 'l to the concentration
and the second assumption tells us that
observe absorbance is like proportional
to the path length in a moment we would
learn physically how it is possible and
why it is so so if you combine these two
we come up with absorbance proportional
to both path length and concentration
and you can remove these proportionality
sign by putting it a constant this
constant is known as molar extinction
coefficient we would be talking about it
later as well so let's try to understand
how this works so imagine we have a
cubit and we have incident light and
light is passing through it and and we
took a small part of this cubit where
there is a small amount of sample of
small length let's call it DL the small
path length and let's call the change in
intensity or the decrease in intensity
if the sample is like absorbing sample
so the change in decline in intensity
for the light in order to pass that DL
amount of distance is di then we can
have come to a relation the
decreasing light intensity per unit
length is proportional to the
concentration and also the intensity and
you can put a minus sign in that because
there is decrease right now let's try to
imagine it physically let's say we have
three solutions and three solution has
different molar ratios and different
molar concentrations so clearly you can
understand different of the different
solutions would have different
concentration of the molecules inside
that now definitely if light passes the
same intensity of light passes through
these three samples the last samples in
the last sample the probability that the
light would be absorbed is more right so
the decrease in the light engine
intensity would be maximal in for the
last sample so already the change in
incident intensity versus that final
intensity is dependent upon the
concentration and now we know how it is
also dependent on the light path because
let's say we have two cuvette one has a
length let us say L and another has a 2l
so the cubed which has more big which
has a length of 12 when light passes
through that cubit the probability is
more that it would encounter more light
more solution particles right so more
light would be absorbed the probability
is more so that's how it is both con
related to concentration and also the
path length now we can start deriving
the beer-lambert law so according to by
definition the decrease in light
intensity per unit length is
proportional to the concentration and
then we can write the differential
equation like this and in order to solve
the differential equation we have to
integrate because we are talking about a
small portion of the cubed in order to
understand what happens how the light
innocent intensity is changing
throughout the cuvette we have to
integrate this throughout the length and
if we start integrating it with proper
limits we would arrive at a four
which is likely log IT by i0 equal to a
constant times concentration into the
path length now by definition these log
ratio is known as transmittance and I
inverse of transmittance is known as
absorbance and absorbance is given by e
epsilon C L so that that is the
beer-lambert law and now we understand
physically how concentration and the
path length is related and why it is
related with the absorbance now
beer-lambert law has wide variety of
applications beard Lambert law could be
used to check bacterial growth kinetics
it could be used for Eliza for
measurement of several disease diagnosis
and cytokine measurement and etc it can
be used to check protein concentration
check the concentration of nucleic acid
and purity of the nucleic acid and many
more so let's talk about little bit of
their usage so first of all a bacterial
growth kinetics can easily calculated by
spectrophotometer so let's say we have a
bacterial culture which is growing
overnight we can take a small amount of
the culture in a cuvette and we can read
it in a spectrophotometer at specific
wavelength and it would give us a
absorbance value later that absorbance
valve from that absorbance value and how
the absorbance value change over time we
can understand the bacterial growth
kinetics very nicely not only that Eliza
is also a direct application of beer
Lambert's law how let's see so in Eliza
indirectly lies or directed I say
anything where you detect the antibody
against a particular antigen is based on
a color reaction whose absorbance is
measured by a spectrophotometer so here
you can see some known antigens are
already coated in the will and now you
add antibody which need to be measured
and in this case it would be like pace
and Shriram serum or anything
then you put the secondary antibodies
with these enzyme enzyme link and
whenever you give a color a substrate it
would give a color which can be measured
measured the color intensity could be
measured by absorbance right and that
would tell us quantitatively that how
much of the antigen is present or let's
say how much of the antibody is present
so that is how Eliza is also based on
beer Lambert's law not only these the
day to day usage of our any molecular
biology lab is nanodrop
using these nano drop people frequently
calculate the concentration of the DNA
or RNA sample and also their purity the
base stacking interaction the PI cloud
of the bases absorb UV light so that is
how we can get a spectrum like this DNA
or RNA absorbs maximally at 260
nanometer and we can measure the purity
of the DNA by this spectrophotometer
mediated measurement when there are
impurity these nano brub can also
display that because let's say in
purification there is a contamination of
like phenol or Bernardin ice with a
cyanide and all these things can be
measured by the nanodrop because
nanodrop previously knows their
absorbance range right that is how
absorbance turns out to be an important
property of any solutions by which we
can understand their concentration and
believe me in day to day molecular
biology lab these absorbance
spectroscopy or bear lamp usage of
Pierre Lambert law is the crucial or the
base of any lab these days I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you